you've got a gal at harvard harvard
senior
who just made a you're talking about
harvard university
theoretically one of the elite
universities in the country this harvard
senior makes a video
in which she says that if you
use the phrase all lives matter instead
of black lives matter
then she is going to stab you
next person who has the sheer nerve the
sheer entitled
caucasity to say all lives matter i'ma
stab you
i'ma i'mma stab you and while you're
struggling and bleeding out i'ma show
you my paper cut
and say my cut matters too
did you hear that word she said
caucasity the word caucus she's
referring to whiteness i
assu call cassidy like caucasian she's
using the word
whiteness the term whiteness as an
insult
now imagine if you did that with any
other race you would be
kicked out of polite society you'd be
investigated for a hate crime
do you think that this this girl is
going to face any disciplinary action at
harvard
no i i don't i think she'll probably get
an award at graduation
meanwhile there's a student at kansas
state university who's being threatened
with expulsion because he tweeted a
disrespectful joke about george floyd
it's a kind of use it's a it's a
often used joke i mean this is an old
joke that goes back very far
the the joke is that george floyd is now
has now been drug free
since he died you know but it's it's a
joke that was came up when whitney
houston died it
comes up whenever a celebrity who is a
famous drug user dies
people say this it's very disrespectful
i you know i don't think it's a little
too soon i don't think we should be
telling
jokes about people who have been killed
like that shortly after
but this kid is now being threatened
with expulsion for telling
a a not very nice old joke
this girl is going to face no
consequences for threatening to stab
people for being white and for saying
the phrase all lives matter
and now you could say she's telling a
joke too okay well the other guy was
telling a joke her joke is more
offensive her joke is
far more aggressive and threatening but
that is the kind of
aggressive double standard culture that
we are living in right now
[Music]
this video is sponsored by blink sale
the revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses
spend less time billing and more time
making bank with blink sale
get a free trial at the link in the
video description